this is a good week right so are in
heaven that is so welcome welcome to you
all very nice to see you all it seems
like just watching you all back safe it
seems like it was a happy train for the
most part Judi was very difficult
because I've seen you in interviews
Michelle but you often say poor thing
when they say who would you like to work
with you often say often Dame Judi Dench
yeah so was it everything you hoped did
you do you remember I cried when I met
you do you remember I got a little
puddle II yeah and then I wanted to curl
up in her lap you you thought you might
break the ice with the first day the
first day she came into the trailer
nobody would approach her and so of
course me being the idiot that I am I
went up to her and do you remember what
I said I looked at her and I go Dame
Judi Dench more like damn
never work in Hollywood
because normally on a set you're the
director you're in charge
but there's a lot of high-status going
on so how did you corral your galaxy of
stars well with great difficulty
actually what you've already seen is
very little that was this is a normal
morning on the train and they wouldn't
let us leave on the train no that's poor
planning but he makes the scenes very
exciting intense Murder on the Orient
Express it opens everywhere tonight and
it is the most phenomenal cast I mean
there's all of you guys and then there's
Olympic cruised Oh Jackie all these
people or starting right things so you
you got all the stars but of course you
know main man Hercule Poirot how
difficult was it to cast that well I
talked to the actor for a long time you
know when you director directors and
detectives I mean in theory they're both
you're looking for the truth so in
theory that that double job is that is
the perfect marriage on something like
this yeah and something like a Cooper
Rose moustache is so famous and you've
gone what left field with your moustache
yes is this a moustache that has ever
appeared in nature sometimes wearing
that moustache felt like you were sort
of french kissing a badger how much of
it is you I tried I'm already starting
my sort of Movember attempt to moustache
it up I have to confess a fall of
follicle failure I attempted for four
months to grow and tease it's what do
you do do you you sometimes grow quite a
thick beard you don't tease it out you
pull it how do you get you get that
great big cities
my beard shaggy is one of the few things
I can do and maybe about five over there
and then just whatever sort of falls in
between his lifts and Josh you have a
moustache as well in the film
unfortunately yes I do
is this like my kids were terrified of
no it's good it's good in the context of
early 20th century when I'm wearing
modern clothes I look like a pedophile
the streets you would see people
watching their children
where's that mustache in the world would
not talk to me that's a there's a new
daddy take it off your face mr. Brown is
paying me too much to do that
[Applause]
if I ask you who you play will you
remember princess Natalia dragomir off
chat around with a lot of jewelry bloody
[Music]